hello in case of one of you missed the
news on the 11th of June South Africa
will kick off the world cup 2010 this
means that Africa will be under the
spotlight during 30 days which is really
historical as European development
commissioner I myself a card to put
Africa high on the user gender but the
power of sport and the passion of the
whole world for soccer will be a unique
ally for me in that endeavor that's why
I'm so happy that for the first time in
history the tournament will take place
on the African soil today South Africans
and all the people of Africa can be
proud of the achievements this world cup
means much more to Africa than just a
football tournament just think about it
millions of people from Europe Latin
America and Asia they'll be looking at
Africa TV and radio media from all over
the world will be reporting on Africa in
a word this man's belongs to Africa I
think this will be an occasion to see
the true face of this continent often
forgotten a dynamic growing continent
with too many untold success stories a
patchwork of countries with young people
ready to take their future in their
hands motivated by all potentialities of
growth and prosperity most importantly I
am sure that this world cup will build a
momentum of hatha enthusiasm for many
people and States of Africa I trust that
Africa will be able to call this
positive energy into even more
successful march two piece growth and
development let me assure you that
Africa will not play
this match allow the European Union is
all these a big estate provider to
Africa and we will continue to support
our African friends in the future I now
look forward to enjoying the world cup
matches well Latin team hasn't qualified
but normally I will support any of the
European themes but this year it will be
different I really wish that African
team will win the World Cup